South Korea we take care of their
economy we take care of everything by
the way being more critical of South
Korea than North Korea here I think we
take care of the military they're right
next door to Kim Jong-un he and I have a
very good relationship people would say
it's not good to have a good relay yeah
it's very good to have a good
relationship it really is
but he's not so happy with uh Biden
he says bad things about Biden but what
I really yeah Trump still seems to think
that when dictators like you it says
something good about you now of course
the truth is far more complicated than
that but this idea that we should be
concerned that Kim Jong-un doesn't like
Biden if it's true right uh no we should
have been concerned by the degree to
which Kim Jong-un felt he could roll
right over Trump